the teams that have the continuity were
more likely to win and look at all the
new moving parts for the tampa bay
buccaneers look at all the not new
moving parts for the new orleans saints
and should we be surprised by the
outcome no we shouldn't you know i i
think we we both saw that this again all
the talent on their roster yes we see
the potential
but you know i i do think a lot of us in
the media and really fans everybody
we're doing a little discredit to what
we call like the ultimate team sport
and kind of disrespecting some of the
other teams in the nfc south especially
like the new orleans saints but yes you
saw it yesterday yeah it's a new cast of
characters mike evans not totally
healthy tom brady not on the same page
with evans getting used to little
nuances in the offense you know and
bruce arians tells you he makes a bad
you know bad interception with the pick
six so it's a work in progress i didn't
expect it to hit the ground running
especially in a year like this uh so
we'll see where they go from here but
i'm certainly not counting them out they
still got a lot of talent on that team
and before i forget the comment from
bruce arians that's the kind of public
candor that tom brady isn't used to
definitely he's used to privately being
ripped by bill belichick but bill
belichick will never say something like
that publicly aryans is not going to to
hesitate so hey tom you know tom that
was your fault bad decision yeah i'm
bored never says that no yeah i mean
right the other one and how much right
how did he say the other one
well then it was uh a bad communication
and evans ran the right route right yeah
evans ran the right route right that was
the key part exactly
and remember last year how many mental
gymnastics bruce arians did to defend
jameis winston every interception he
threw it seemed like wasn't his fault so
look everybody gets coached differently
and this is a new reality for tom brady
maybe he's going to be nicer to you in
the film room maybe he's not who knows
he's going to find out soon but publicly
he's not going to pull punches he's not
going to protect you he's not going to
give the grunts and the one-word answers
that are in part aimed at shielding the
players from extra and unnecessary
scrutiny and criticism from the media
and from fans so that's part of tom
brady's new reality chris let me tell
you this yeah
when i looked up yesterday
at 4 25 eastern or right about them
right about the time the game was
getting ready to start and i saw tom
brady in that white jersey with the red
12. shocking
it was jar and we knew it was coming it
was jarring yeah to see him on a
sideline
in a tampa bay buccaneer road jersey i i
i and we've known it for six months
it was just it was the weirdest and most
prominent lightning bolt of the day for
me to see that visual yeah i i agreed i
can we still you know see him or or see
that image in my head of him running out
of the tunnel yesterday and just
thinking how weird that was and the fact
that he was unable i mean just not just
in that uniform the way he looked
everything like that uh it's just crazy
you're right it's gonna take some
getting used to it was like that with
cam newton up in new england but
uh either way
yeah the new england i mean excuse me
the tampa bay buccaneers got a lot of
new moving parts right now they they do
and brady was not on the same page he's
still learning the nuances of that
offense
and honestly new orleans didn't look a
whole lot better on the offensive side
of the ball either but brady helped them
you know with the two turnovers kind of
get jump started that way
and the way the game started out i
thought brady and the co and company
were really going to be hitting on all
cylinders on offense
yeah right down the field right brady
scores a rushing touchdown seven nothing
just to see that on the screen tampa bay
seven new orleans nothing that that was
uh
i thought right sign that they were
going to go at least toe to toe yeah but
the saints eventually pulled away fueled
by those mistakes right right yeah yeah
yeah uh brady and all 23 for 36 239
passing yards two passing touchdowns one
rushing touchdown two interceptions and
three sacks so uh jameis winston watches
on because right now brady's on pace for
32 touchdowns and 32 interceptions maybe
he can be mr 30 30 for the second
straight year
for for it it never happened before live
quarterback
in a row we talked about irony last week
and how you know you you're talking
about how atlantis morissette messed
that up is that irony when the the old
quarterback of the other team who has
been replaced because he threw too many
interceptions now he's sitting on the
other sideline and the new quarterback
comes in and it does the same thing
would that classify as that
i think it's closer to irony than a
black fly in your chardonnay okay i'm
not sure whether or not it fits within
the definition on all squares and i
don't know whether or not this is irony
but i looked at the
the uh the final box score the game log
that the nfl puts together because
that's really the only place to get all
of the detailed information about who
played who didn't snap percentages etc
the only guy from the entire new orleans
saints active roster that didn't get
into the game yesterday was jameis
winston wow
the one guy who surely would have loved
to have a piece of his former team you
think sean payton would have found
something for jameis winston to do
against his former team well maybe
that'll happen at some point during the
next match-up he'll infuse him in there
some way just to give a little jab back
at the buccaneers or whatever else that
you know that may be but this early in
the year they're still trying to find
their way to new orleans they certainly
weren't like overly impressive with the
way they looked defense you know did
play well obviously with the two big
turnovers that jump started the football
team but you know i would think sean
payton drew brees they're going to go
back and watch that film today too and
they're not going to feel necessarily
real good about
their performance either you know their
their inability to kind of create big
plays in the past game we kind of saw
that arise once again mike the offensive
line didn't dominate the way we're used
to it you know used to seeing it uh
dominate the line of scrimmage but i
know that's a good front with the bucks
but yeah those were two teams yesterday
were working out the kinks and it was
just the one team that you know like you
said to start to start the show here one
team's played together been battle
tested the quarterback knows the offense
and the nuances of it and there was no
mistakes or i'm not on the same page as
you or we didn't see that the same way
and we saw another team that had those
issues and that was the difference in
the game
the good news for the buccaneers the
schedule gets a little bit softer
they've got the panthers coming to town
although the panthers may not be the
easy out that everyone thought they were
i'm sure we'll be talking about that
over the course of the next two hours
then it's at denver chargers and at
bears before a visit from the packer so
next four games not like going to new
orleans and playing the saints how long
do you think it's going to take brady
to really get into
the rhythm that he needs in order to
thrive in tampa and make good on the
prediction by many in the media
including maybe the buccaneers that get
to the super bowl i think it's going to
take a few weeks i do i i think it could
be one of those things where you know
week three week four somewhere in that
range
is to where you start to see okay yep
bruce aries has got a good feel for what
tom likes called in certain situations
tom
understands what bruce and byron left
which mean by certain calls you know
there's there's little hidden messages
that you learn through experience
talking to your officer coordinator and
head coach about nuances of plays where
they explain to you you know hey you
know tom i called this play because i
was thinking this and at the very worst
we can do that right and i think those
are things that they're going to
continue to just work on through
dialogue and figuring out what works
best for their football team so i don't
expect it to be a whole lot better next
week but like you said it's lesser
competition and another big part of that
mike is they need a healthy mike evans i
mean we know he's a difference maker and
he was non-existent yesterday so when
you have no mike evans and then no run
game to go on that
i don't care who you are tom brady
superman whoever it is it's going to be
it's going to be tough sledding against
a team like the new orleans saints
on the other side of the uh
field drew brees 18 for 30 160 yards two
touchdowns 160 yards for a guy that's
had
5 000 yard seasons over and over again a
guy who's been a
passing yards machine that's a quarter
for drew brees 60 yards not a full game
right yeah it's the one
mike again i don't mean to be this first
off
we saw two old quarterbacks yesterday
they were they're old i don't know what
else to say
we're not gonna sit there and never go
oh my gosh what a play blah blah blah
they have to beat you with the offense
the scheme dissecting you with their
brain and the occasional throw but mike
i'm already week one going i'm a little
scared about new orleans can they
stretch the field can they get people to
back off i mean we never saw
a throw down the field other than two
throws to jared cook one i want to say
was like in the second quarter and then
one was third quarter or so but that was
the only thing we saw all day as far as
an aggressive
mindset or type of play from the saints
offense and i don't know it just scares
me uh this early this early on
and you know yesterday the sunday splash
reports were back and everywhere you
looked it was how close tom brady came
to signing with the saints and it was a
two-pronged approach first before drew
brees decided to play again and then
even after brees decided to play
it continued and it came from everywhere
and let me tell you something i have i
have it you want my monday conspiracy
because i i have a conspiracy theory too
but i'd love to hear this go ahead
i think all of this came directly from
brady and his camp with his agent being
the conduit for the story being handed
to nfl network espn and fox here's why
in all of the talk that came out
yesterday about the possible
destinations for tom brady and the bears
were won the the saints got most of the
focus the charges were mentioned again
there was never a whisper about the fact
that he wanted to go to san francisco
and supplant
his agent's other quarterback client
jimmy garoppolo that was never brought
up a single time
you know mike that's first off
my conspiracy theory was the same exact
conspiracy theory except i didn't even
think about that aspect you're right
very odd we didn't bring up the team
that he we know he wanted to go to i
mean yes i thought the same thing though
when i when i was kind of eating
breakfast yesterday morning like you and
you know you're watching the shows and
everything else this report came out and
the first thing i thought of is i went
man did tom brady let all this out to
kind of screw with drew brees and the
saints on game day knowing this was
going to come out right now and and kind
of play that type of game i mean that's
really that's exactly what i thought now
i don't know if that's true but it just
seems very coincidental and even more so
when you add that little fact that i
missed uh you know yesterday
here's how the sausage gets made folks
someone like don yee calls around to
these reporters and says i got a hell of
a story for you for the first sunday of
the season are you ready for it oh yes i
am okay let me tell you this though
price of admission is when talking about
these dynamics that i'm about to
disclose to you there's one thing that i
have to not let be mentioned if you
promise me you won't mention that i'll
tell you the whole story and because the
space is so competitive 99 of the
reporters out there will do that deal
and the manifestation of it is it was
crickets yesterday on something that
wasn't just reported chris it was talked
about by everyone involved kyle shanahan
admitted it jimmy garoppolo admitted it
john lynch the gm of the 49ers admitted
it this wasn't a secret and yesterday it
was like it never even happened yeah
it's really i might i'm not gonna lie
you know the story came out i thought of
my conspiracy theory i went into
football mode i never thought of that
aspect of it but uh it certainly seems
like that when you start to sit here and
kind of flesh it out
read between well the bottom line is
flush it out you know one of them read
between the tea leaves flush it out
flush it out it didn't work the saints
still won although brees did not have a
drew brees day leonard fournette did not
have a leonard fournette day no five
carries for five yards and his long was
six yards which means on the other four
carries he was minus one combined yeah
it wasn't pretty i mean i don't think
anything you can really look at the
buccaneers offense all day and go oh
that was pretty i mean ronald jones he
was a little better than leonard
fournette but you know that's the other
aspect of this of this team we want to
see can they be
you know a dual threat type of offense
you know even in jameis winston's good
and bad there's always been lack of a
running game there in tampa there's
never been balance so that is something
they're gonna have to continue to work
on especially for a guy like brady
because brody is a great play-action
passer as well uh and that would be
something that you know helps him helps
a guy at that age slow down the pass
rush do those type of things so there's
work to be done done in tampa there's no
doubt about that
tasty mill also was not used much
considering how much money is being paid
to him by the new orleans saints one for
one a late throw in the game kind of
something to put on film to get teams to
think about down the road because it
really wasn't necessary it was a
well-designed play a flip to you know a
lateral from drew brees to taysom hill
and he throws it 38 yards to alvin
kamara so one for one for 38 yards three
carries for 13 yards one catch for 14
yards again doesn't cry out 16 million
guaranteed on a two-year contract but
it's early it's early yeah and uh you
know i'm i'm not i'm not going to throw
my guy taysom hell overboard because i
still think he's got the skills to be uh
a very good quarterback in that offense
especially if if drew brees uh is going
to continue to have 160 yards a game
yeah right no doubt well and again
they're paying taysom hill a lot of that
money too is just the for the rights to
retain him for what he could be in the
future and i think they see somebody
that could be the heir apparent to drew
brees and we know he does have a special
skill set he does pop when he's on the
screen there's no doubt about that and
from the way the offense looked
yesterday and the way and you know where
michael thomas hurts his ankle a little
bit in the in the matchup and he's
dealing with that they might have to
infuse him more into the offense this
week just to get a little spark and get
some explosive plays going
i'm glad you mentioned michael thomas
because it was a fire drill yesterday to
find out something about the ankle
before we talked about the game last
night on football night in america and
you could see
the the
the ankle get injured alvin kamara fell
on michael thomas down near the goal
line late in the game it was garbage
time but when do you pull your offense
off the field you're only up 11. no it's
not like you're going to pull up you're
getting them in shape it's their first
game you want to get them going a little
right and stuff happens it's amazing
injuries like that don't happen more
often with all the bodies flying around
on an nfl gridiron but
i was told last night that thomas was
walking around the locker room wouldn't
let the trainers look at it but they
were determined to get a look at it and
then after that chris it was crickets
which tells me that sean payton
intervened at some point this is my
guess and said nothing more about this
gets out
uh and we'll find out wednesday on the
injury report whether to what extent
michael thomas practices is he injured
they they don't want people knowing yet
they want they know there are minimum
requirements as to what they must
disclose and nothing must be disclosed
before wednesday so the fact that it's
silent
makes me think that yeah that it
definitely continues to merit paying
attention no no question no doubt about
that and you know he's such a big part
of the offense and even you know before
that though you know again they they had
a hard time getting him involved
yesterday the one thing and i'll be
excited to watch the game film that's
something you know i'll do today with
ron jaworski is uh you know just the
fact that
it popped out to me a lot in different
moments
again they they went out of their way to
not get exposed by michael thomas in the
short passing game and alvin kamara in
the short passing game and when you take
that away
you know this is going to be the big
question for the saints for me as we go
on here what's going to be the next
phase of the offense what's drew brees
going to do after that to create create
plays and i think that's something
they're going to really have to think
about in new orleans uh to make sure
their offense is well-rounded and
tougher to defend
and as the drew brees deep ball has
continued to diminish yeah that's what
teams are going to do exactly right
you're going to move closer and closer
to the line of scrimmage it's like
moving the batters up when the guy can't
hit the ball over your head you're i
mean the fielders are going to move all
batters fielders whatever same
difference they know who we mean you're
going to move the fielders up until he
can hit the ball over your head i
remember drew brees in camp saying that
he worked on it in the off-season on his
deep ball i mean father time has worked
on your deep ball that that's the
reality no doubt and that deep ball that
once that deep ball is gone it's not
going to come back there's no exercise
you can do that's making that
that making that deep ball come back i
mean maybe you get the absolute most out
of what you can still exactly right but
it ain't coming back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports